hello and welcome to this video playing
international math Acadia blue water
let's see you that is recorded no name
okay so there's nothing to forget early
h5 here okay just prevents g-form so
probably back to to this plan on let's
see dyami so he wants to go be five
after all and the good thing about this
set up with black as you can just a
shower move move move move move and when
it's never going to be completely
terrible this this stuff yeah like here
already blundered yeah already plundered
with with the friggin you for porn yeah
take it to come on take it no it doesn't
okay it feels a little bit dangerous
awesome still maybe you could have taken
it so what to do here mm-hmm not nice
maybe still my have no square I have
actually have no square I am good h4
which is not brilliant
what to do I don't like Queen d3m yeah
but I completely missed time to go over
the whole thing here Rob Bishop e3 it
was so surreal miss time move now is
fine it's difficult actually turn before
him can add some home night on each
floor okay that doesn't look good
okay my position looks extremely weird
night on h4 night on a to know take some
need some reorganization to make this
more harmonious yeah I'm not quite sure
what are you thinking about it to be
perfectly honest just we should be seven
or Bishop g7 okay until at least control
d5 maybe you can take a 4 by the heavy
five so probably not
well known castles
so the shirt back on can I can double on
this if I absolutely one turn I have a
completely ridiculous night on edge form
that night would be like somewhat better
okay same thing applies for the a
two-night 291 and then what well at
least I can't play night see one after F
and I may have play groupie one and the
91 simply because the night has no other
square to go to wants to take on edge
for won't really know that I'm really
happy about if it does that
[Music]
let's to go where I mean currently I've
got this converter so i can actually
retreat the night you this is a move
well I think I'm fine him they're just
murky the pollution but just objectively
speaking why it should be in good shape
but much more space and and so on and so
on just all the strategic assets that
you can have this is the only thing that
you can try and like do something here
on the G file ok this is also hanging
let's grab that now I thought f5
actually yeah again it's very murky but
just just need the better the the night
is bad
it would be very logical to bring it
back into the game but I think this is
probably not bad
it's simply absolutely ignoring what i'm
doing here i think just like play
whatever I don't know still still murky
here in the night each form to take that
the rook will take e 600 a.m. maybe 6 e
takes you seven is a pretty substantial
threat
check check that's made Queen c7 mate
black resigned yeah I was a very strange
game I absolutely miss played the
opening so this is kind of normal and
age 5 is a move but i'm not sure how
good that is I really don't know maybe
there's some other way of handling this
am NOT not with g3 I turned ok I don't
know the theory of the slide so he
played those standard moves on the
queenside and probably I have to open
prove somewhere here it gets it gets
really awkward hem Bishop e3 is probably
wrong and it doesn't it's like it that
much but yeah this is the problem yeah
and it wasn't clear to me why you cannot
take only for an in fact he can of
course this was played in me Atlanta
yeah I wasn't really sure because I mean
I cannot take these six and I have to
give up the light square shop this is a
funny move that that's probably a key
idea I'm gonna blacken and extremely
good shape ok quindi three inches six is
still it still looks bad for white yeah
but ok it at least computer doesn't give
me a huge disadvantage I'm a little bit
surprised by this evil am I really
losing you for I meant by two nights our
awkward yeah
perfectly wearable it seems so it seems
that this is this is really good like
doubling up yeah I mean that even I
don't my nights that are not in a
position to cover the porn yeah it seems
to be good yeah yeah yeah this this
isn't bad I don't think that this is
totally bad for me they are the computer
I mean this is depth 20 that's not a lot
so I'm willing to believe that I'm worse
but I think it's very hard to say what
the what the real evaluation is this
looks like a complete mess yeah computer
started on some what somebody equal ish
grounds and this doesn't seem to work
okay yeah I was gambling here Bishop g2
e6 was my idea can't seem to book night
I don't really have something great here
Bishop f3 hate this and now I'm wing
[Music]
check yeah and that's that slides out
nothing much that he can do light takes
was meeting made immediately chat and
this is also not good yeah i mean this
is checkmate made again yeah something
like that check so it's a computer line
can also lead to some mate yeah i'm
better opening result ready
this line is quite interesting for
whites but have no idea what what
happens after after this war ok guys
thanks for watching